it's been two weeks since i got my hands
on this beautiful
blue sleigh of aluminum and glass and i
have to say that this is gonna be
apple's
most popular phone in years
[Music]
i'm going to do this review a little bit
differently instead of looking at the
improvements compared to last year like
most
i'm going to take a step back and
approach it from an older iphone user's
perspective
sharing both the positives and the
negatives with this redesign
and how these changes will affect your
real world daily use
i'll also share why i think everybody
that's been waiting for the right time
to upgrade from their old iphone
should stop waiting and finally make the
jump instead of waiting for the iphone
13.
i'm going to talk about the design the
display speakers cameras battery life
and much more but let's start out with
what's going to affect
every single person out there and that's
cell reception
let's forget about 5g for a second since
not everybody has it yet
the regular lte is so much faster on
this phone
if you struggle with slow speeds and
poor signal like i did in parts of town
the iphone 12 will be a big improvement
at my church
at the few spots that i even get a
signal i went from six megabit per
second download and 0.3
up all the way to 38 megabit per second
down
and two megabit per second upload that's
over six
times faster and it's made a world of a
difference for me
in the last two weeks areas i had no
signal i now have signal
and places where the internet was super
slow it's now fast
that's because apple did a cheap out
this year and they use the very best
cellular chips on the market
and unlike previous years the non-pro
iphone has the best antennas
just like the pro version now onto 5g if
your city has 5g
it could be up to 20 times faster than
lte but what's more important is that
the iphone 12
has more 5g bands than any other phone
which means it's guaranteed to work once
your city
actually has 5g now let's touch on
battery life since you may have heard
that 5g drains your battery faster
and it's true apple does have a new
smart data mode to give you the best mix
of performance and battery life
but if you want you can manually switch
to lte since
it's already so fast the iphone 12's
battery life isn't
amazing but it's much better than most
iphones
mr who's the boss does killer battery
life tests and the new 12 beat out the
11 by about an hour and a half
and the previous 10r by over two hours
the crazy thing is that the iphone 10r
was known for its great battery life
so if you have an older iphone the
difference will be huge
an iphone 12 will get most people
through a full day without needing to
top off
a big part of this is the new a14
processor which is the first five
nanometer processor on the market
that's a big deal because of its battery
efficiency and its crazy fast speeds
everything is super smooth and fast to
be honest
it is way too fast to even use it all
and almost no app can make full use of
all this extra performance that's
exactly what you want though
because it means that three years from
now it will still handle
every new app coming out without a
problem and if you keep it for five
years
you'll still have a usable iphone if you
play mobile games the iphone 12
is great for a few reasons first it can
play every game out there at the best
graphics settings
and likely will be able to do that for
the next couple years
second the display looks fantastic but
more on this in just a bit
and third the speakers which sound great
for games and videos
the speakers are louder and richer than
ever but if you're somebody with an
iphone that's a few years old
the difference is incredible we have
stereo sound from the bottom and the
earpiece speakers
and comparing it to an iphone 8 or 10
it's now
perfectly balanced and compared to an
iphone 7 or older
the stereo sound is much more immersive
making movie watching
actually enjoyable now let's jump to the
screen and apple has
finally perfected it for the first time
an only display is used in a non
thousand dollar iphone which means that
blacks are perfectly black
and you can watch hdr video where colors
and brightness really pop
last year's iphone 11 had a cheap lcd
which wasn't very sharp
and it dimmed if you viewed it from the
side and the 11 pro had an oled screen
that looked blue from the side
but this year fixes both of those issues
and it looks great
now let's get to the first issue that
you might not have with your older
iphone
and that is how easily the screen
scratches
in the last few years apple has been
making the glass tougher against cracks
and this year they are using crystals
which they call ceramic shield
which with the new design makes it four
times stronger against drops the issue
that comes up is that when glass
is tougher against cracks it is easier
to scratch
and even though i've been super careful
with it i've already noticed a few of
them
if this bugs you like it does me i would
suggest getting a glass screen protector
which i'll link down in the video
description
along with a few cases now for those of
you that don't use
cases or screen protectors cracks will
be much less of an issue than before
a big part of this is the old but new
design
straight out of 2010. to be honest i
wasn't super hyped about it like vadim
was
but as soon as i got it in my hand i
fell in love the square edges do make
the phone feel thicker
even though it's actually much thinner
than an iphone 11 but because of that it
feels so much more secure in the hand
the back is all glossy glass and it's
also
much more grippy compared to older
aluminum iphones
but it's definitely a fingerprint magnet
especially with darker colors
speaking of magnets the iphone 12 has a
bunch of them
inside to support max save charging and
a bunch of upcoming accessories
now i don't think this is a big deal yet
but in the future it definitely will be
now what is a big deal is the
waterproofing
this thing can stay 20 feet under water
for 30 minutes which is a huge upgrade
to the older iphones
and makes water a non-issue the bezels
are much thinner now and if you're
coming from an older iphone the screen
fills up the full front as well
which makes it more expansive while
keeping the phone small
because of this if you're somebody that
has an older plus model for the larger
screen
but you find it uncomfortable a regular
iphone 12
should be a very nice middle ground now
let's talk about that notch
and face id yes it does get in the way
sometimes if you watch videos in full
screen and it can cut into some games
and yes you do get used to it overall
it's mostly worth the trade-off in order
to have face id i say mostly
because in 2020 many of us are wearing
masks and face id just doesn't work with
them
when you're not wearing a mask though it
is amazing in my opinion much better
than touch id
and apple does also say it's much more
secure it also allows for portrait mode
shots using the front camera which look
really good especially if you have
distracting backgrounds you want to hide
let's jump into cameras and this year is
an excellent time to upgrade
the front camera and rear wide and ultra
cameras are the same exact ones in the
pro
you're just missing out on the telephoto
camera which improves the quality of
zoom shots
and lets you take longer portrait mode
shots unless you have a phone from last
year you most likely won't have this
ultra wide and i have to say it is
really nice to have
allowing you to capture shots you
wouldn't have been able to i
loved mine last year but i was always
disappointed with the quality
and thankfully apple has made every shot
much sharper
the biggest upgrade though over last
year's and previous iphones are
nighttime shots where we can now take
night mode shots with all three
cameras now this requires you to hold
your phone for a couple of seconds
and then the a14 processor combines
multiple photos to make them brighter
and sharper
the difference is incredible and it not
only makes
dull dark photos great but allows you to
take photos you otherwise
couldn't now along with that the regular
rear camera takes portrait shots of
people in
objects which adds blur to the
background like pro cameras
for anybody upgrading from a couple year
old iphone or older
the camera difference will be noticeable
especially at night
this also goes for video where for the
first time ever iphones can shoot
hdr which records video more true to
life that's brighter and more colorful
overall i have to say that the iphone 12
is the most complete iphone i've ever
used
and if you've been waiting to upgrade
now is the time it will be great today
and even a few years down the line
thanks to its massive jump in chipsets
and the new design i have very few
complaints this year
i guess one is that the iphone 12 no
longer comes with a power adapter
only a usb type-c charging cable which
won't work with your old five one
adapter
i would suggest buying anker's nano fast
charger for only 16 bucks
which is much smaller than apples and it
will charge your phone
really fast of course you could also buy
apple's magsafe charger but you'll still
need to buy a power brick
the other downside is that the price
went up by a hundred dollars compared to
last year
and maybe even thirty 30 more depending
on which model you want to buy
but i can't really blame them because
the iphone 12 costs apple
much more to build compared to last
year's iphone 11. if i had to boil it
down to one
issue it would be that after you upgrade
to 128 gigs of storage
which i would suggest the price is so
close to the pro model
that it makes it a really tough choice
if you want to see my full comparison
after one week of use to help you decide
which one you should buy
click that video right over there and if
you enjoy this video why not subscribe
by clicking the circle above
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below thank you guys for
watching this has been max and i will
see you
in the next video
[Music]
you